avec david ali baskin avocat cofondateur
du collectif robe noire et j'ai les
jeunes bonjour et merci d'être avec nous
sur rt france les autorités redoutent
aujourd'hui que les manifestants les
gilet jaune ne rejoigne et certains
lieux symboliques plusieurs secteurs
sont interdits dans la capitale
notamment aux abords de l'elysée de
l'assemblée nationale de l'hôtel de
matignon évidemment sur les champs
elysées est ce que vous comprenez ces
mesures alors que l'on redoute la
présence de quelques centaines d'ultras
radicaliser alors moi je prend pas du
tout en fait l'interdiction de ces
secteurs comme vous l'indiquez il ya peu
près une quarantaine une cinquantaine de
rues ou de lieux qui sont interdits par
le préfet de police de paris
c'est c'est complètement
incompréhensible et là et la préfecture
indique oui alors qui aura une centaine
de casseurs je ne vois pas comment il
peut savoir une centaine de casseurs
on est toujours en fait dans la même
perspective depuis disons depuis un an
un an et demi où le préfet se permet en
fait de le porter des atteintes à la
liberté de manifester euronantes en
étendant les les secteurs interdits donc
conséquence d'un conséquence il peut
avoir les manifestations sauvages
on sait qu'en ce bas les gens sont
colère s'est énervé et ça peut donner
lieu en fait à voilà à des rixes en tout
cas lille gestion du matière l'offre qui
est complètement de catastrophique et
une gestion des manifestations toujours
catastrophique de la part du préfet de
police de paris
et c'est ce qui explique selon vous
alors c'est un première intention dont
on vient de parler depuis le xviie
arrondissement de paris
mais bien sûr mais bien sûr quand vous
interdisez des secteurs de paris
ban dans ce cas là évidemment les genres
sont sont énervés et sont énervés
ensuite qu'il ya des provocations
policières et ensuite et les
interpellations et ça se passe très mal
mais en tout cas ce que je peux
constater c'est que la préfecture
continue à faire des interpellations
inventive jusque là je viens sortir du
commissariat du xviiie arrondissement
vous avez un nouveau compère donc julien
moreau est journaliste indépendant et
qui en dépit de sa carte de presse a été
placé en garde à vue
tout ça parce qu'ils avaient
masques à cartouche il avait en fait
désastreux mans dans son sac pour voilà
pour se protéger mais évidemment aucune
arme
donc si vous voulez il ya eu des
interpellations encore préventive
aujourd'hui à l'égard le paquet
l'allemand n'a pas encore là toujours
pas modifié ses techniques devient
mannequin langue explique en fait voilà
qu'il ya ya ya de nombreuses fonctions
on a vu aussi sur des vidéos des lives
des 10 des manifestants complètement
pacifique il n'avait pas signe de signes
distinctifs de gigny jaune d'autres
étaient contrôlés sur les terrasses de
café mais les policiers se permettait de
les interpeller de les fouiller et de
les contrôler alors qu'ils étaient sur
le terrain est en train de boire leur
café du matin
alors on va revenir sur la doctrine du
maintien de l'ordre avant ça ce sont 27
personnes qui ont été placées en garde à
vue depuis ce matin un important
dispositif judiciaire est déployée
aujourd'hui pour déféré rapidement les
éventuels fauteurs de trouble qu'elle
regarde ce que vous portez là dessus non
mais c'est toujours c'est toujours
pareil si vous voulez en orbite toujours
au même problème
l'interdiction de manifester dans le
secteur
un petit peu épais ou bourgeois de paris
donc le le préfet l'allemand en fait le
continuera cette politique on arrivera
en fait comme ça des à des
interpellations mais la majorité des
interpellations qui ont eu lieu ce matin
à paris c'était des interpellations
préventif sous couvert de participation
à un groupement en vue de commettre des
violences ou des dégradations il de
mémoire j'ai pas vu de deux policiers de
violentes et j'ai pas vu voilà des
attractions doute rage qui pourrait être
effectivement grave encore une fois je
vous dit en fait c'est d'interpellations
préventives ont eu lieu près des gares
ensuite c'est un dispositif de maintien
de la sécurité ben ça c'est ça c'est
normal c'est mais c'est le cas dans
toutes les manifestations mais nous a
pas échappé que depuis depuis près d'un
an et demi en fait que les les
les le pape est allemand en systèmes
systématiquement tous les samedis des
arrêtés pour interdire aux jets les
jaunes de manifester dans les secteurs
alors vous évoquez la doctrine du
maintien de l'ordre
le ministre de l'intérieur gérald
darmanin a présenté hier notamment deux
nouvelles à mesure qu'ils sont appliqués
dès aujourd'hui notamment concernant une
nouvelle grenade de désencerclement
utilisé dès ce samedi présentée comme
étant moins dangereuse concernant
l'utilisation du helvètes du lb d accord
obligatoire désormais d'un superviseur
pour chaque tir ce sont de bons
aménagements selon vous alors concernant
les grenades pour moi je considère que
le niveau des intérieurs et juste de la
communication voilà de la communication
pour racheter pour essayer d'empêcher et
le moelleux de gens possible aux
manifestations
le du père sont peu importe la nature de
la grenade ou grenade et dangereuse
voilà par essence donc on essaye un
petit peu de faire peur aux gens en
disant qu' une nouvelle grande l'inde
qui allait arriver
qui va être utilisé pour éviter que des
gens viennent manifestations concernant
la levée des noms mais il n'y a pas de
rire en fait
est-ce que qu'est ce que propose le
ministre de l'intérieur c'était un
superviseur voilà il ya superviseurs qui
décide si vous tirez le lbd sur les
manifestants mais nous je peux me les
manifestants demandent c'est
l'interdiction de cet anti est considéré
comme une arme de guerre dans les
nations unies pour obliger qu'il ya deux
ans les nations unies avait condamné
avait interpellé la france concernant
les violences policières notamment
concernant l'utilisation du lb 10 40 ou
interdire aux policiers en fait de tir
avec ces termes c'est une arme de guerre
merci beaucoup d'avoir un prix temps de
répondre à nos questions directes sur rt
france david libeskind cofondateur du
collectif robe noir et gilet jaune
je veux vous remercier